oui je serai très rapide puisque nous
avons peu de temps mais on pourra
aborder évidemment la question du
logement est quand même la question
essentielle de paris et c'est l'échec
essentiel avec la propreté vous avez vu
cette semaine les dégâts de la propreté
à paris eh bien le logement c'est
l'échec majeur de madame hidalgo et de
monsieur delanoë depuis 14 ans
claude goasguen a rappelé les chiffres
cette politique est inefficace
inefficace parce que j'ai le plaisir où
j'ai le regret de vous l'annoncer
aujourd'hui
fin septembre il y aura non pas 180
milles mais deux cent mille deux cent
mille demandeurs de logement à paris
c'est le chiffre officiel il essaye de
le cacher mais c'est le chiffre officiel
des services de la ville lorsque delanoë
est arrivé à paris il y avait 90 mille
demandeurs de logement donc c'est plus
qu'un doublement des demandeurs de
logement à paris
c'est un échec sans pareil dans une
capitale de la taille de paris
et puis si vous regardez les chiffres
elle est inefficace également en matière
d'attribution des logements
on en a pas parlé tout à l'heure lorsque
chirac et tiberi était à la mairie de
paris il y avait douze mille 12000
attributions chaque année aujourd'hui en
est à 10500 c'est à dire qu'on en a
perdu plus de 1000 et ça s explique tout
simplement parce que il ya eu très peu
de créations de logements très peu de
logements neufs
environ 2000 par an en moyenne 2000 2500
par an alors qu'on en faisait 6 milles
avant est plutôt dur conventionnement
c'est-à-dire delà de la mise en place de
logements qui existe déjà et qui est
déjà occupé ce qui fait qu'en réalité en
matière d'attribution
vous ne pouvez pas aller plus loin que
10500 ça explique aussi d'ailleurs
les deux cent mille demandeurs de
logement puisque - vous construisez moi
vous attribuez et moins vous attribuer
plus vous avez demandeurs de logement la
boucle est bouclée et c'est ça la
politique qui est menée actuellement et
qui est amplifié
on nous a promis 7000 logements par an
sous delanoë ils n'ont pas été fait on
nous a promis aujourd'hui dix mille
logements par an c'est dans programme de
madame
dago je vous le dis aujourd'hui ils ne
seront pas fait nous aurons les chiffres
à la fin de l'année au mois de décembre
ce sera plutôt autour de 7000 avec une
catastrophe nationale
on nous avait promis 500 mille logements
par an et on en fait à peine 300 milles
et cette politique elle est également
injuste elle est injuste parce que les
classes moyennes sont exclues de paris
et ça on a des chiffres très précis
qu'on pourra vous livrer les classes
moyennes n'ont plus leur place à paris
lorsque vous êtes à un ménage avec deux
salaires des salaires moyens vous ne
pouvez pas vous loger à paris parce que
les logements sociaux ne sont pas faits
pour vous il n'ya pas de logements
intermédiaires et évidemment l'accession
à la propriété puisque la ville de paris
refuse de faire de l'accession sociale à
la propriété
l'accession à la propriété n'est pas
pour ce genre de classe moyenne
parce que les prix du logement à paris
ont plus que doublé sous delanoë hidalgo
en 14 ans c'est invraisemblable n'y a
pas une seule capitale que qui a connu
une telle pénurie de logements en europe
alors que faut-il faire trois pistes
très rapidement puis je cèderai la
parole à valérie la première piste c'est
évidemment qu'il faut construire plus et
qu'il faut construire mieux car on
construit mal à paris la deuxième piste
c'est qu'il faut construire pour tous
accession sociale à la propriété tous
les maires socialistes en première
couronne four de l'accession sociale à
la propriété
ça permet à des gens qui sont dans les
logements sociaux d'en sortir
lorsqu'on a une promotion
professionnelle ça arrive encore dans ce
pays et d'accéder à la propriété c'est
la première étape de l'accession à la
propriété faire également du logement
intermédiaire pour les classes moyennes
troisième point il faut construire à
l'extérieur de paris
et ça sera la grande ambition de la
métropole du grand paris qui va devoir
au 1er janvier n'ont pas 2016 mais 2017
établir un plan de logement et
d'hébergement métropolitain est là avec
la reprise de la région parce que nous
allons reprendre cette région nous
aurons les moyens coercitifs vis-à-vis
de madame hidalgo et vie
avid sa politique du logement par la
région en supprimant un certain nombre
de subventions et en lait réaffectant
sur du logement pour les classes
moyennes et par la métropole du grand
paris en définissant un nouveau plan
d'hébergement et de logements beaucoup
plus favorable aux classes moyennes est
beaucoup plus favorables à l'accession à
la propriété
je vous remercie